what's going on y'all this is rob and
i'm in cancun it might be a little bit
windy here uh
i'm inebriated so here's the thing i
have been thinking recently i'm thinking
i mean like it's something i think about
a little while now i should launch a
youtube channel where i read y'all
bedtime stories right because like a lot
of you guys are like rob you got an
amazing voice and i'm like yeah maybe i
do and you're like maybe you do and i'm
like maybe
maybe
i do want to be a friend
but it's like yeah like i definitely
want to be
uh that's a little burger king
commercial i think it'd be cool to make
videos where i literally just help you
all the assets fall asleep because i
have the voice for it i would do
treasure island in all honesty but the
problem with doing a video like that is
it wouldn't help you fall asleep because
the story's so exciting i get excited
recorded i get excited recording it man
i get hyped
i don't know let me let me let me know
if you guys want me to make a youtube
channel where i read you guys bedtime
stories
i hope y'all fall asleep it'll just be
like
it'll be like an asmr channel i don't
know
i'm drunk just ignore me